can we talk about going back to the
movie now that they're the secrets are
all out what was the toughest secret for
you to keep et was exclusively with Star
Wars The Force awakens actress Daisy
Ridley I mean the thing I found funniest
was that I was the the child and I don't
like people worse over time these people
like well like you're Han Solo's
daughter and in my head I was like how
do you know like have you seen the film
clearly not that wasn't that was the
funny one it wasn't that difficult we
were all keeping this like wonderful
magic alive yeah and and it paid off
because people were like oh my god I
think that's the best part it's like
everyone was like oh thin fins for said
yeah
shaky but he did wheel the lightsaber so
I'm gonna say he is for sensitive okay
because you know we've all got that
force within us don't we episode 7 is
coming to blu-ray April 5th I believe
there will be some bonus footage
hopefully some fun behind the scenes
yeah it's gonna be very exciting for
everything obviously there isn't in the
film for the fans to be able to share in
that too